this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer we have been
hearing it for years climate change is
happening what I'm about to present to
you is fact these are reliable
measurements with multiple peer-reviewed
papers confirming the information
atmospheric carbon dioxide levels are
the highest have been in over 400
thousand years confirmed by our analysis
of hundreds of samples of Arctic ice
cores tree chorus and isotope ratios and
fossils average global temperatures have
risen by 0.8 degrees Celsius since the
Industrial Revolution began were 2/3 of
that change occurring since 1975 the
evidence is overwhelming this is fact
you are wrong if you deny it if these
trends continue and I really shouldn't
say if because they will continue we are
going to continue seeing stronger storms
more heat waves and droughts sea levels
will continue to rise even after the ice
caps have vanished in the summer months
in about 30 years and to really make you
motivated to care about this the world's
economy will suffer we have been making
strides in the technology required to
reduce our emissions of carbon dioxide
but the changeover is happening too
slowly the most effective thing our
world has done in the past 10 years in
battling carbon emissions was going
through a global financial crisis
countries like my own are continually
missing carbon targets we are going to
face up to 600 million euro in fines
every year after 2020 until we fulfill
our promise of reducing our carbon
emissions by 20% that money is going to
come out of our pockets through carbon
taxes maybe then we will start to take
climate change seriously we aren't
making significant decreases in carbon
dioxide emissions we've only really
leveled out which is not good enough so
if we aren't making a difference by
reducing emissions maybe we can reverse
climate change
maybe we can engineer our climate and
there has been multiple suggested
methods of doing that in this new video
series we're going to explain how
several geoengineering methods intend to
work and their potential impact on the
world's climate the first plan we will
examine is a forestation
a forestation is pretty self-explanatory
plant trees allow them to grow and store
carbon in their wood the problem we run
into is finding large enough spaces to
plant forests though
significant impact on the climate and
that would not negatively affect the
economies of the countries employing the
method taking land that could be used
for agriculture just isn't a realistic
solution no one is going to agree to it
our options are limited but we happen to
have huge expanses of land on earth that
are not being used for anything
productive deserts now I know what
you're thinking
deserts are not the best place for
growing anything but with water
desalination technology rapidly
advancing this isn't as far-fetched as
it may seem we are going to examine the
feasibility and effect of a forestation
in the two largest subtropical deserts
in the world the Sahara and the
Australian outback these are the perfect
candidates for a forestation neither
have large competing human populations
agricultural activity or large natural
animal and plant populations
conveniently they are also in the
subtropical zones where a 12 month
growth cycle is possible maximizing our
carbon capture potential to maximize our
potential further we need to pick a
suitable tree the tree we choose will
need to be suited to this climate be
evergreen grow rapidly and be useful as
a commercial resource the Australian
eucalyptus grandis will be the candidate
for this study which also comes with the
added benefit of being a habitat for
these cute little ships before even
bothering to worry about how this would
be done let's first see if it's worth
being done let's first look at the
Sahara as an example ultimately we're
trying to sequester atmospheric carbon
dioxide by storing it in wood every
10,000 square metres could hold about
1,000 trees and taking this patch of the
Sahara between the 16 degree and 50
degree longitudes we've about 9,800
billion square meters of land
ignoring land needed for infrastructure
that's about 980 billion trees planting
a forest of this size would increase the
world population of trees by 33% that's
a lot of trees estimates showed that
this would capture between 6 and 12 Giga
tons of carbon per year for about a
century before I would meet a
steady-state where growth would slow and
carbon dioxide in would equal carbon
dioxide out six to 12 Giga tons would
capture between 16.3%
and 32 point six percent of our
emissions per year with humans
generating a total of thirty six point
eight Giga tons of carbon dioxide in
2017 ideally we wouldn't
let the trees grow and forget about them
we would systematically cut them down
and use them for construction synthetic
feedstock or convert them to liquid
biomass fuel to replace our dwindling
fossil fuel supplies and burn that fuel
in a power plant with its own carbon
capture technology which would reduce
emissions further and produce new
economies for these desert regions
Australia's desert is about 60% the size
of the Sahara and so we could add an
additional 60% to that figure to bring
our best-case scenario to just over 50%
capture of our emissions per year
bringing our emission levels per year
down to levels equivalent to that of the
70s on the surface this seems great but
what effect would this actually have on
our environment there are multiple
things we need to consider first of all
is the irrigation itself a managed
forest of this nature would need 500
millimeters per year of water which
equates to 4900 billion meters cubed of
water per year for this number of trees
where is all this water going to come
from and at what cost fresh water
supplies are obviously rare in the
Sahara but surprisingly not as rare as
the Australian outback the world's
largest groundwater aquifer actually
resides beneath the Sahara and is shared
by four countries Egypt Libya Sudan and
Chad and it is not alone new studies
show the Sahara is sitting on vast
reservoirs of groundwater this
groundwater supply is vital for many
African countries with it often being
the primary source of fresh water for
their populations draining at an
industrial scale like this comes with
ethical concerns as it is a
non-renewable resource even these vast
reservoirs of water would run dry within
a few years when pumped on this scale
however the cost of desalination of
seawater has dropped dramatically in
recent years thanks in large part to
countries like Israel the United Arab
Emirates and Saudi Arabia who have
invested in the technology and all get
over 50% of their drinking water from
desalination plants this technology
still requires energy and energy comes
with a cost
but monetarily and as a source of carbon
dioxide it requires approximately 1.5
kilowatt hours of energy to desalinate a
meter cubed of water we then need to
pump the water to a height for
distribution with the average elevation
of the Sahara
450 meters this would require a further
2.5 kilowatt hours per meter cubed
bringing our total energy consumption to
4 kilowatt hours per meter cubed of
water supplied the cost of this in terms
of carbon footprint and actual cost will
vary with the energy source used but
considering the location and nature of
the project a mix of solar power and
biomass energy with carbon capture
technology attached to its exhaust
should be used let's focus on a purely
solar powered process for now as biomass
is more expensive and has a larger
carbon footprint without carbon capture
technology though it would become
cheaper as the project matures thanks to
the cheap source of fuel on its doorstep
solar energy cost about $0.10 per
kilowatt hour with a median carbon
footprint of 72 grams per kilowatt hour
putting all this together the total
energy needed to irrigate this forest
with 4900 billion meters cubed of water
will be 19,600 terawatt-hours a year at
a cost of 1.96 billion dollars a year
and a carbon footprint of 1.4 gigatonnes
of carbon a year ignoring infrastructure
costs which would likely push the
initial costs into the trillions this
puts our total carbon capture for the
Sahara at a best-case scenario of 10
point 6 gigatons a year at a cost of 184
dollars per tonne of carbon dioxide
captured expecting poorer African
nations to fund this alone is
unrealistic
so it'd be reasonable to expect
countries to pay for this project
through carbon taxes like those that
will be placed on Ireland in 2020 and
thus allowing them to offset their own
carbon emissions with funding to the
project a litre of petrol when burned
emits approximately 2.6 kilograms of
carbon dioxide thus placing a carbon tax
of about 48 cent per liter of petrol
could pay for the project if we sell
four billion liters of petrol with the
added carbon tax which is about the
total petrol and diesel consumption of a
small country like Ireland so it's
possible at a high cost but if the
project can stop climate change maybe
it's worth it that's the next problem we
need to address what effect will de
forests actually have on the world's
environment with the help of climate
models we can start to get a clearer
picture of what all this money and
effort would give us temperature being
the top of our list of concerns local
temperatures would be affected most jute
evaporative cooling caused by the
increase in soil moisture this would see
clouds and increased local precipitation
substantially allowing us to reduce our
ongoing costs with heavier irrigation
only needed in drier months from May to
October local evaporative cooling does
not decrease overall global temperatures
as it just transports the heat within
the Earth's atmosphere
critically we want to reduce the amount
of heat retained in the Earth's
atmosphere by reducing greenhouse gases
allowing heat to escape the system
entirely one of the biggest concerns
with a project like this is the
modification of Earth's albedo albedo is
a measure of how reflective a planet is
a higher albedo that means we reflect
more sunlight back into space rather
than absorbing the solar radiation and
thus increasing the temperature forests
have a very low albedo they are
literally designed to absorb solar
radiation whereas snow and ice have a
very high albedo they reflect quite a
lot of noise as the sand placing forests
over regions where sand once resided
will reduce the world's albedo alone it
will actually negate the heat lost
through reduction in greenhouse gases in
this climate model however the cloud
seated from the forests hoped to
counteract that decrease in albedo the
study shows an overall decrease in
surface temperatures but a significant
increase in ocean temperatures
surrounding the forests the conclusion
of the primary paper used for research
in this video is fairly ambiguous with
no definitive answer to whether the
project would have a net negative or net
positive effect on global temperatures
while other papers that did not factor
in the increase in cloud cover affecting
albedo suggesting that a forest station
in the Sahara and Australian outback
would increase global temperatures by
0.12 degrees Celsius by 2100 compared to
a control model where no a forestation
occurred we also need to worry about the
decrease in fertilization that would
occur due to Sahara dust no longer being
transported to the Amazon and the
Atlantic Ocean which would likely
decrease plant and plankton growth and
thus negate much of the carbon
sequestration that this forest would
provide the desalination plants would
also need to carefully manage their
output of highly concentrated saltwater
as dumping undiluted saltwater into the
ocean would wreak havoc on the local
aquatic environment
overall I think the idea is an
interesting thought experiment but
practically shows little evidence of
benefit for the labor and cost needed
and could potentially open a Pandora's
box of unforeseen consequences
ultimately our best tool for combating
climate change will be to decrease our
carbon emissions and that solution is
staring us right in the face
through cheap solar and wind energy we
need more people acting on this we need
more people funding and researching
alternative energy sources you can
become one of those people today by
taking this course on solar energy on
brilliant in this course you will
discover the principal methods of
harvesting energy from sunlight from
both concentrated solar power and
photovoltaic cells starting from the
fundamental physics principles by the
end of the course you will be able to
answer practical engineering questions
and have a better understanding of the
considerations and servicing
utility-scale electric grids the best
way to understand is by applying
concepts yourself which is exactly what
brilliant allows you to achieve this may
initially sound complicated and scary
but brilliant guides you through
problems that are broken into digestible
sections that bring you from knowing
nothing to having a deep understanding
of the physics and math that underlie
our lives a feeling inspired then go to
brilliant org ford slash real
engineering and sign up for free and the
first 73 people that go to that link
will get 20% off their annual premium
subscription as always thanks for
watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
[Music]
you